alright guys I'm gonna be honest I've
been slacking off on Instagram recently
last year I set a goal for myself to get
to a million followers and nowhere near
a million followers I've actually lost
10,000 followers so probably because I
haven't posted since December 11th why
haven't I posted since December 11th
good question it's because it's hard to
come up with good content I want to put
good content on my Instagram so recently
I saw something perfect something I had
to do for my Instagram I'm gonna play
the clip right now
I'm gonna recreate that for my own
Instagram and get to a million followers
okay so first thing I need I need to buy
the pendulum hi I'm I was wondering if
you guys have if you guys sell like
pendulums like a like a pendulum
I need like a ball on a string that like
swings left basically I'm making a video
I'm making a video for BuzzFeed where I
wanted like sensor my own genitals with
like a little ball that swings it's yeah
it's just basically like like a little
like a metal ball that if I like let go
it'll yeah like on a desk but I'm gonna
be using it for like it's gonna be far
away it's gonna be like a depth
perception thing and I like swing my
hips and it's gonna swing where my penis
is where like my general is supposed to
be okay oh okay great so if I come by
right now I can just grab it yeah cool
thank you so much okay I'm good day wait
I think I just read that guy out so I'm
walking to the store right now a little
embarrassed because I know the moment I
get in there and I grabbed the pendulum
the guy was on the phone with there's
gonna know exactly why I'm buying it but
got to do it for the followers okay the
moment I put the pendulum on the counter
the guy looked me in the eyes and I just
saw confusion where he was like you were
the guy on the phone why are you using
this for your penis
cowboy hat the pendulum one of these
little balls is supposed to cover this
is gonna be harder than I thought
okay first I need to figure out how to
set up the camera like how far do I need
to be from this thing and the camera for
this little thing to cover up my peepee
I'm not saying my peepee is a big thing
but this is a very little thing this is
going to be a challenge for anyone
average sized peepee big size TV small
size TV this is difficult I got to stop
saying pee pee it's weird
wow this is so hard
okay ready and wow it's so fast am i
moving with it hey hey hey right now I
feel like the ball is too big like this
okay I can't see if I'm in line so I'm
gonna have to call a friend down to
watch the screen
wait focus on me focus focus on me okay
are you focused focus on me you dumb
camera okay I'm gonna have to call down
a friend so that he can tell me if I'm
matching up because the screen is way
too small and I can't see little it's so
good I did I buy one that's too small my
god so much bigger than my penis so all
right so just go stand like let's start
with a it completely still no there
let's see it's too much it has to be
like yeah that he's is slower no oh oh
oh is that it yeah
hey so I could sing oh my god
I need a bigger one that's the
conclusion yeah I think the ball is too
fast and it's not big enough
you need a bigger ball I need a bigger
ball let's go we're gonna do
[Music]
back for another one is there any way to
check how big this one is inside you can
open it well certainly look better the
speed already yeah the speed is way
better look at that yeah I don't be so
fast maybe try it like I guess that's
too fast right left right left right
left right left right left right left
I feel like this thing is not yeah it's
like jerking around right left right
left right left look so insane from here
it's just there's there's parts where
you are synced up right left right very
very close that's it you got it that's
literally it
that's perfect so now I just take my
pants off yeah I'll leave the room first
then all right Chris left the room it's
time for me to get naked I put two
chairs in a table at the door so nobody
can get in here never what I thought you
know when I was a little kid that I
would grow up and I would be in an
office where in the studio I would be
getting fully naked and swinging my body
to the rhythm of a pendulum
[Music]
how does he start this he's like
oh my god this is so uncomfortable and I
don't know if I'm doing it but things
are flopping all around let's watch back
the footage see if I did it on the first
try I was so close to doing it but then
there was a little bit of a slip slap
when I got out of synch so I have to do
it again because I didn't perfect it ah
[Music]
that one completely did not work first
of all I was out of focus second of all
I had to blur the out-of-focus because I
missed the ball so much that even out of
focus you could see that I missed it's
really hard to do it without a friend
telling me if I'm in frame and stuff and
like I have to be able to monitor the
screen myself I'm gonna attempt it a
couple more times myself if I fail we're
just gonna bring a friend I don't even
care please please tell me that works
I'm sick of seeing my own penis on
camera I'm in frame and I hope I'm focus
[Music]
oh I'm not right I did that work please
I tried something new get a little hip
action there I did it
that is the weirdest like 15-second
video I've ever seen myself that
breathing is so we're gonna know
thrusting inappropriate I can't believe
I'm releasing this on the Internet
I just re-watched it on the computer
close up and in the very beginning the
moment I take the hat off there's a
little slip I have to redo it Eric this
is for Instagram an Instagram takes hard
work
okay I gotta work hard for Instagram I'm
seriously about to cry ha yes yes yes
there was so much penis showing that
time
[Music]
please please was that the one please
was that the one focus on me
come on that one was perfect it was it
was all blurry eyed understand how to
get this camera to focus come on focus
on this we focus please work right now
this is the last try and I should my
butt oh and again my butt
oh okay okay I'm about to cry I just
watched the footage I think I did it
I also definitely I'm about to get like
six-pack ABS that was extremely
exhausting I'm out of breath I don't
know why I have to like breathe as I'm
doing it but I I'm inviting Chris back
to review the footage let me know if
it's good enough to post on Instagram so
uh yeah whoa you absolutely did it I did
it
absolutely okay so I have the video on
my phone now and I'm gonna upload it to
Instagram right now if this doesn't go
viral my family will disown me if this
does go viral my family will disown me
crying emoji Kendra hashtag pendulum
challenge hashtag viral inspired by a
taquito a 100% underscore oh no okay
guys so it's been exactly two days I
haven't checked my Instagram I don't
know what's happened but I have high
hopes I work really hard I think it's
funny video so let's check it out okay
okay I got 122 thousand views on the
video in two days which is a lot that's
basically a hundred percent engagement
which is unheard of so I'm sure I gained
some sort of followers because there's
got to be like outside viewers on this
deal let's check how many followers I
got okay okay I gained um I gained no
followers zero absolutely no followers I
probably lost a couple hundred if
anything um I I don't know what to do I
don't I don't know I don't understand
Instagram what do I need to do to go
viral and become an Instagram celebrity
do I need to do it without the pendulum
I don't know I don't know what do I
didn't do all right I know I can't give
up that easy nobody successful gave up
that easy you know you got to keep
working you got to keep trying you got
to fall down fall down and then get back
up right that's the same so I'm gonna
figure out Instagram I will stop at
nothing until I get to a million
followers on Instagram I will get 20
million
[Music]